diez minutos diarios de redoble de
campanas es el homenaje que la catedral
de san jorge' de ciudad del cabo hará
desmon tutú desde este lunes hasta el
próximo sábado 1 de enero en esa fecha
la conocida como catedral del pueblo
durante su mandato como arzobispo
acogerá el funeral del que fuera premio
nobel de la paz
a las 10 de la mañana del sábado primero
de enero el funeral se realizará aquí y
también es aquí donde sus cenizas serán
enterradas desde el arzobispado y la
propia fundación de tutu advirtieron que
la asistencia será limitada debido a la
contingencia sanitaria sin embargo
iglesias y organismos oficiales de todo
el país serán habilitados para
homenajear a la voz de los sin voz como
lo nombró este lunes el presidente del
país a su llegada a la ciudad del cabo
white
el bin laden es poder
fue valiente fue franco y nos encantó
por eso porque era la voz de los sin voz
fue la única persona que hizo campaña
por la justicia por las personas que
viven con vih por ayudar a la comunidad
lgtb más y por las personas abatidas y
oprimidas community
ya que lo presti por sus ideales lo
enfrentaron en varias ocasiones con el
poder eclesiástico son precisamente los
miembros de esos colectivos oprimidos
quienes honran su recuerdo con numerosos
homenajes
no importa quién seas no importa tu
sexualidad horas a lo que sea que haya
en tu cuenta bancaria realmente promovió
la idea del amor y la aceptación a cada
persona y esa es realmente una de las
lecciones que creo que deberíamos llevar
con nosotros de color morado se
homenajea a quien barack obama recordó
como la brújula moral de sudáfrica
morado es también el color escogido por
el ayuntamiento de ciudad del cabo para
venerar a su arzobispo más universal